entre visitas a la playa el suroeste de
francia
estos parisinos optan por unas
vacaciones con actividades inusuales
nosotros vamos al centro de vacunación
en langley los franceses ahora pueden
recibir la primera y segunda dosis de la
vacuna en cualquier parte del país hay
menos restricciones para las personas
respecto a la reserva de citas para
venir a diferentes centros nosotros
podemos tener la primera inyección en un
centro y la segunda en otro alrededor
del 40 por ciento de los franceses están
completamente vacunados y el gobierno
espera que más sigan el ejemplo al igual
que el número de contagios aumentan las
preocupaciones sobre una cuarta ola la
semana pasada los casos nuevos
aumentaron en un 60% en comparación con
el promedio de la semana anterior y el
lunes se registraron más de 4000
contagios mientras tanto el número de
personas hospitalizadas con el virus se
estabilizó durante los últimos dos días
luego de haber disminuido durante varias
semanas
en un intento de mantener las cifras
bajas el presidente de una norma con
anunciará medidas el lunes un movimiento
probable según un funcionario del
gobierno es la vacunación obligatoria
para los trabajadores de la salud el
consejo científico dice que las tasas de
inoculación para el grupo son demasiado
bajas especialmente en los hogares de
ancianos donde sólo la mitad de los
empleados han recibido las vacunas
algunos políticos están pidiendo que se
amplíe el uso del pase de salud lo que
significa un requisito de vacunas o
pruebas negativas para restaurantes
teatros y otros lugares en lugar de solo
clubes nocturnos y grandes eventos